this morning with inflation on the rise  and no end in sight many of you are  trying to plan ahead and get ready to  retire and that includes women but what  can they do to improve their financial  future well according to american  century investments women have only 80  percent of that retirement income  compared to men many of them also  dealing with other circumstances raising  kids caring for aging parents  investor simple sebastian suggests that  you keep it simple if you're trying to  build a fund so just remember that your  financial health is just as important as  your physical health to get started  carve out some time and do some homework  look at your bank accounts know your  numbers your savings your debt the  interest you're paying  sebastian also suggests that you draft  an investment timeline to help you  choose the right ones and she says  timing really is important and it may be  worth the risk if you feel one  investment will pay off over another